[music] there was
just a bang and there was nothing flying like that,
although the windows were open at night
339 and as if there
should have been a sound there was nothing
[music] it
just started shaking, it
felt like this whole house was looking
out the window and I live on the side where there is
least  damage I think it’s strange there’s
no damage Well, relatively a
little bit okay it’s scary But I think
damn compared to
[music]
let’s go have a look
This is a question that probably concerns more
our specialized department of the
Ministry of Defense
You know that these drones that are
today  they are sick, neutralized,
that is, in this regard, in this peace plan, it
is accepted that with regard to the
development of the defense system,
to ensure more intensive work.
This is a matter of the Ministry of Defense